pierre yves le goff a créé le génie il
ya 20 ans sa spécialité le traitement de
surfaces notamment pour l'aéronautique à
plus de 50%
avec la crise il a dû stopper les
contrats de neuf intérimaires reste 35
salariés avant il avait des commandes
pour 25 jours de travail la visibilité
s'est encore réduite maintenant c'est
seulement de 5 à 8 jours
c'est très compliqué parce que nos
clients qui sont des entreprises plus
importantes que nous ne savent plus nous
dire ce qu'on va voir dans deux jours
donc si on réduit trop la voilure le
risque c'est qu'on ne puisse plus les
servir et si on ne réduit pas assez
c'est qu'on a une charge financière qui
est trop présente
donc c'est un exercice très périlleux
qui se décident chaque jour chaque jour
une décision est prise et qui peut être
remise en question quant à moi je reste
optimiste mais c'est compliqué l'un de
ses clients ses cris la situe à temis à
besançon j'écris là en ce moment
plusieurs jours par semaine les ateliers
sont à l'arrêt
ces nouvelles presses à un nouvelle
façon horizontale
et ça nous permet de pouvoir passer de
travailler la nuit aussi donc c'est
aussi une question de productivité
vous avez peut-être de nouveaux
équipements il ya personne pour les
faire fonctionner ouais bah ça fait très
mal au coeur c'est triste un endroit au
salarié vous les fait travailler combien
de jours par semaine en moyenne trois
jours par semaine en moyenne
créer un travail à 75% pour
l'aéronautique
cette année thierry bisiaux prévoit une
chute de 45% de son chiffre d'affaires
suppression des cdd de l'intérim mise en
place de chômage longue durée
mais pour le moment pas de licenciements
envisagés préfère aller sur déjà ce
chômage longue durée à voir en parallèle
de sa toute cette action
cette action commerciale pour
diversifier trouver d'autres marchés
trouver de voie de développement et pour
le moment il n'est pas il n'y avait pas
de question de parler de de licenciement
ce qui est important c'est des doors
dans le réel et surtout de s'ouvrir
parce que c'est le moment oui si on se
ferme on peut vraiment avoir des soucis
il faut s'ouvrir s'ouvrir aux autres
écoutez les opportunités sortir de
l'entreprise aussi pour aller chercher à
faire ça c'est le boulot des équipes
commerciales et du chef d'entreprise
les entreprises qui travaillent pour
l'aéronautique en bourgogne franche
comté peuvent adhérer à un groupement
aéro microtech son rôle fédérer ces
professionnels est dynamisé le réseau
indispensable en temps de crise les
chefs d'entreprise sont un peu seul mais
le fait de pouvoir rencontrer leurs
pairs et de pouvoir dialoguer et de
trouver des solutions ensemble est
vraiment une force pour eux on essaie
d'ouvrir les entreprises à ce type de
démarche pour pouvoir voir comment est
ce qu'elles peuvent aller trouver
ailleurs et utiliser leur savoir faire
et trouver ailleurs d'autres types
d'activités l'année 2000 21 sera crucial
pour les entreprises du secteur
aéronautique qui emploie en bourgogne
franche comté
seize mille salariés